el resultado del ciclón Irán muchos de
los árboles en este cultivo de plátano
quedaron afectados la fruta que todavía
no había madurado cayó al suelo y Dejó
de ser apta para la venta El agricultor
Frank Sugey Tuvo una idea innovadora
para salvar su producción
No queríamos tirarlo todo entonces se me
ocurrió tratar de hacer harina
empece el proceso de secado y me puse en
contacto con un chef local
Gabriel le violó a que quería hacer un
grupo de trabajo para hacer harina con
los plátanos que ya no servían
gracias al boca a Boca nos organizamos y
pudimos empezar las pruebas para ver si
realmente seríamos capaces de lograrlo
queríamos usar todos los plátanos que
habían caído al suelo después de en Irán
[Música]
Paula gay es el encargado de convertir
los plátanos en harina en su laboratorio
de investigación dirige una asociación
dedicada a descubrir y promover nuevos
productos naturales la harina de plátano
verde podría convertirse en una
alternativa para la harina de trigo pero
primero el laboratorio necesita
desarrollar una manera de procesarla
aquí están los plátanos
contamos todos los trozos y los
trituramos hasta convertirlos en harina
les voy a mostrar
se necesitan 5 kilos de plátano para
hacer un kilo de harina una rentabilidad
cuatro veces menor que la de trigo
Este es el producto final que será
empacado
lo más estimulante es trabajar con los
productores de plátano porque están muy
interesados y realmente quieren crear
este nuevo producto
sobre el procesamiento y el uso del
producto
todavía tenemos que descubrir el valor
nutricional de esta harina
estamos trabajando de cerca con todos
los actores en la cadena de valor y eso
es muy emocionante
el chef Gabriel le violó hace pruebas
para conocer los distintos usos que
puede tener esta harina en el
restaurante su receta favorita hasta
ahora
primero para las crepes utilizo leche
vegana también se puede hacer con leche
normal
dos huevos 30 gramos de azúcar
30 gramos de aceite
75 gramos de harina de plátano con una
cucharadita de café molido y lo
mezclamos
[Música]
es una harina que absorbe mucho los
líquidos no estoy familiarizado con este
tipo de harina estamos más acostumbrados
a trabajar con la de trigo y Esta es una
alternativa local desde los productores
y procesadores hasta la persona que lo
lleva al mercado
[Música]
Hay que organizar toda la logística la
cadena entera
y yo soy el último eslabón
esta receta es para promover la harina
de plátano
pero también hay que dejar que el
ingrediente se exprese hasta poder
entenderlo y desarrollar la receta
correcta
la harina de plátano verde es lo
suficientemente Versátil para usarse
tanto en platos dulces como salados
Este es un pastel hecho con batata dulce
con una salsa blanca de queso y pepino
El plato principal es lasaña al estilo
Colombo aquí hice una imitación de
algunos platos locales con hoja de
casaba Y por último un postre sencillo
[Música]
esta experta en nutrición afirma que la
harina de plátano es una buena opción
para varios problemas de salud
es una muy buena comida para personas
con sobrepeso o diabetes
tiene un índice glucémico muy bajo
también es buena para reducir la
inflamación para la gota y la artritis
[Música]
sube las defensas
y ayuda a tratar la diarrea
es una fruta excelente
con más nutrientes que el plátano maduro
Entonces es buena para las personas que
hacen deporte para los niños y para la
gente mayor pero esta harina local se
sale del presupuesto para gran parte de
la población a casi 30 dólares el kilo
es significativamente más cara que las
demás
no hay mucha demanda para la harina de
plátano
ponemos algunos carteles con información
para ayudarle a los clientes a escoger
otras alternativas distintas al trigo
este experimento nos permite ver qué
piensan los consumidores sobre el
producto
[Música]
Sería muy bueno poder desarrollar otras
opciones distintas al trigo
no solo a partir del plátano verde
el mercado de harina de plátano es una
industria creciente a nivel global Y a
medida que los consumi se preocupan cada
vez más por su salud se espera que esta
tendencia continúe